o aumento na próstata vai começar a
partir dos 40 anos de idade e vai se
tornar significativo Nas quinta e sexta
décadas de vida trata-se de um
crescimento Benigno de tecido e nada tem
a ver com câncer Apesar de que as duas
doenças podem coexistir no mesmo órgão
mas o hpb a próstata benigna que é uma
sigla que significa hiperplasia
prostática benigna ou crescimento
Benigno da próstata não vai virar câncer
nemhum câncer vai virar Benigno ao longo
da vida de um homem existe um risco de
40% de que ele vai ter que tratar dessa
doença e uma chance de 10% que vai ter
que operar aos 60 anos de idade Metade
dos homens vão ter sintomas de
dificuldade de esvaziar a bexiga